[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka und nabend die
ukraine und auch moldau sind eu
beitrittskandidaten geworden dass sich
die eu staaten am abend darauf geeinigt
haben ist so oder so ein historischer
schritt dazu kommen wir im laufe der
sendung noch ausführlich schauen aber
erstmal auf die wirtschaftlichen folgen
des russischen angriffskrieges der
europa erschüttert und zugleich so neu
sortiert in deutschland ist robert
habeck heute in den alarm modus
gewechselt auf die zweite stufe des gas
notfall platz die dritte wäre dann die
ausrufung des notfalls ab dann darf der
staat gas rationieren und zu teilen so
weit sind wir aber noch nicht habeck
läutet die alarmglocken vor allem um
industrie und privaten verbrauchern zu
warnen winter is coming frank buchwald
berichtet
solche sätze sagt kein minister gerne
robert habeck aber hatte heute wohl
keine andere wahl
das ist von nun an ein knappes gut in
deutschland das sage ich obwohl oder
gerade weil die versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland aktuell gewährleistet ist
notfallplan gas seit 30 märz gilt die
frühe warnstufe nun beruf der minister
ganz offiziell die alarmstufe aus in der
notfall stufe entscheidet dann die
bundesnetzagentur wer noch gas bekommt
so weit sind wir noch nicht aber
wenn es uns nicht gelingt im
industriellen im privaten bereich
deutlich gas einzusparen oder gas aus
anderen quellen dazu zu bekommen dann
kriegen wir im winter ein problem die
erdgasspeicher sind aktuell nur gut zur
hälfte gefüllt viel zu wenig beklagt
nicht nur die opposition in berlin sie
fordert von der regierung einen plan und
die koalition konnte ein plan den wir
seit wochen
einfordern hier im deutschen bundestag
bitte bereiten sie auch das vor was noch
kommen kann wir machen das maximale
tempo damit dass in diesem land gelingt
herr spahn ich weiß nicht ob es ihnen
aufgefallen ist aber das ist teil
unseres plans um dieses land aus der
krise zu führen im gartenbereich in die
sie dieses land geführt habe das ist der
plan ersparen derweil dreht russland den
gashahn immer weiter zu über die
jamal-pipeline kommt in mahlow praktisch
nichts mehr an über die mega anleitung
erreicht waidhaus nur noch ein drittel
nord stream 1 ist um 60 prozent
gedrosselt und weitere probleme sind
absehbar
vor allem haben wir ein wartungsfenster
vor uns wo nord stream 1 auf null
gefahren wird und wir wissen schlicht
nicht wie es danach weitergeht schlechte
nachrichten besonders für verbraucher
wir rechnen damit dass in diesem jahr
alleine jetzt schon die haushalte mit
zusatzzahlungen im schnitt von 1000 bis
2000 euro rechnen müssen und das kann
sich im laufe des jahres noch deutlich
erhöhen noch dürfen die versorger die
hohen weltmarktpreise nicht an die
verbraucher weitergeben lange aber
dürfte das nicht gut gehen diese
situation wollte keiner aber wir müssen
da jetzt auch gemeinsam durch das heißt
es braucht die instrumente dass diese
erhöhten preise dieser erhöhten kosten
nicht bei den versorgern hängen bleiben
als wäre das alles nicht schon
unangenehm genug sollen auch
kohlekraftwerke länger strom erzeugen
moderne gaskraftwerke werden
heruntergefahren für einen grünen
klimaschutzminister ist heute wirklich
kein guter tag
darüber wollen wir mit robert habeck
reden genannte arbeit gut normgröße ist
das so dass der minister im moment vor
allem bundeswirtschaftsminister sein
muss und der klimaschutzminister
haarberg dahinter doch schmerzhaft
zurücktritt
entscheidung da will ich nicht auf dem
heißen brei herumreden ich wollte die
kohlekraft reduzieren und jetzt muss ich
kraftwerke die schon aus dem betrieb von
wieder reinbringen weil wir einfach in
einer gas notlage sind wir bauen die
windkraft auf der gesetzlichen ebene in
einem rasendem tempo aus den sieben oder
acht gesetzte gerade im deutschen
bundestag und die nachfrage ist eben
auch da die industrie will schneller weg
von den fossilen energien
wir haben große effizienzprogramme am
start die gebäudesanierung endlich nimmt
sich richtig fahrt auf also da ist
natürlich auch eine richtig tolle
dynamik und aber wenn ich mal so
verbissen tage haben wir diesen dann
früchte ich mich danach und denke oh
guck mal auf die vier jahre vielleicht
gibt die bilanziert doch gut aus naja
aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so als
würden jetzt plötzlich millionen
genehmigungen für windräder erteilt so
dass man sich keine sorgen machen müsste
denn sie haben ja jetzt eben aus gutem
grund diese stufe 2 sozusagen gezogen
und sie wollen ja deshalb auch die
kohlekraftwerke aus der reserve holen
weil nämlich die einer erneuerbaren noch
nicht reichen
wer vor allem muss man sich noch mal
klar machen wofür wir das gas vor allem
brauchen 15 prozent gibt in den energie
also in den strommarkt das stimmt diese
15 prozent werden jetzt reduziert durch
die kohlekraftwerke oder ganz weg
genommen vom markt durch die
kohlekraftwerke und die kohlekraftwerke
wiederum kann man durch solar und wind
ersetzen das gas das wir vor allem
brauchen geht aber zu 30 und mehr
prozent in das heizen wir unsere wohnung
unter wasser warm gemacht wird und in
die industrie und das sind die erstmal
andere träger damit sind die
erneuerbaren nur indirekt etwas nämlich
wenn man mit erneuerbarer energie selber
gas herstellen kann das kann man aber
wasserstoff durch elektrolyse herstellen
also will damit sagen der ausbau der
erneuerbaren ist tatsächlich der
schlüssel am ende auch um uns von gas
unabhängig zu machen und deswegen ist
genehmigt die da ist millionenfach ist
die genehmigung nicht das stimmt schon
aber die also ich meine jemals bayern ja
über ich würde sagen zehn jahre haben
die die hände verschränkt und gesagt
aber das einfach nur nicht bei uns jetzt
wollen sie 800 windkraftanlagen bauen
ist nicht besucht uns jetzt bis 800 das
hilft uns auch jetzt nicht bis zum ende
des jahres wenn der herbst kommt und der
russische präsident den gas handlung
wirklich ganz abdrehen wird absolut
richtig ich wollte auch nicht ablenken
ich wollte nur sagen es passiert auch
etwas auf dem bereich des klimaschutzes
und
damit das gas abgedreht wird
ich würde lügen wenn ich sage ich
schließe es aus es ist tatsächlich so
dass putin schrittweise die menge von
gas immer mehr reduziert hat das folgt
einen klar erkennbaren plan nämlich die
preise in europa in deutschland hoch zu
halten damit dann ich würde gar nicht
sagen ökonomische sorgen zu steigern
sondern gesellschaftliche unruhe zu
schweigen zu steigern und damit die
geschlossenheit die ist ja doch gab
aufzubrechen und deswegen sind die
maßnahmen die wir ergreifen nicht nur
energiepolitische maßnahmen sondern
maßnahmen zur geschlossenheit der
gesellschaft dass putin nicht gewinnt
darum geht es noch werden diese
preiserhöhungen ja nicht eins zu eins an
die verbraucher weitergegeben noch geld
mir langfristige verträge noch hat die
bundesnetzagentur nicht diesen so
genannten preis mechanismus aktiviert
das jetzt etwas sperrig aber
letztendlich heißt das abdanken
innerhalb von einer woche die
gasversorger die preise wirklich an die
verbraucher abgegeben wird das noch
geschehen das ist ein zweischneidiges
schwert einerseits für haushalte mit
kleinen einkommen zum beispiel dafür
kleine betriebe wirklich fatal schwierig
andererseits wenn man die preise nicht
hochgehen lässt dann gibt es auch kein
anreiz zum sparen
ja und wenn man sie nicht weitergibt und
kippen uns möglicherweise die
unternehmen das versorgungsproblem ist
das große energieversorger riesige
mengen von gas einkaufen verträge haben
und diese mengen von gas werden jetzt
nicht geliefert weil russland sich nicht
mehr liefert die verträge existieren
aber fort sie müssen jetzt das gas auf
dem weltmarkt besorgen der welt mag es
drei mal so teuer wie er war als die
verträge geschlossen wurden das heißt
typischer paradoxerweise mit jeder
kilowattstunde gas die sie ausliefern
machen sie - und irgendwann gibt es kein
geld mehr mit dem man gas kaufen kann
keine banken mehr kredite geben weil es
ja ein minus geschäft ist und dann
fallen die um und dahinter stehen die
stadtwerke hinter den stadtwerken
stimmen endkunden stehen industrie oder
wirtschaftsunternehmen und dann hat man
einen domino effekt im energiemarkt das
muss in jedem fall verhindert werden ein
instrument ist die preis weitergabe an
die kunden aber sie sagen zu recht es
ist ein zweischneidiges schwert und ein
sehr scharfes weil dann die kosten
unmittelbar sofort quasi in einer
kündigung des vertrags und einer neuen
aufstellung des vortags bei uns landen
und dann hat man wenn man nicht aufpasst
ein großes soziales problem in
deutschland aber es gibt natürlich schon
auch menschen die tatsächlich noch gas
einsparen könnten also wir haben 20
millionen haushalte glaube ich die eine
ganze etage
haben was könnten sie denen anbieten als
anreiz manche schlagen eine energiespar
premier vor wenn man dann wirklich wenig
gas benutzt weniger als im jahr davor
dann bekommt man geld vom staat als
belohnung ja ich weiß gar nicht ob man
alles belohnen muss an der stelle die
preise sind ja so hoch ist eigentlich
anreiz genug sein müsste jetzt gas zu
sparen es gibt eine faustregel dieser
art pro grad weniger heizen schwartmann
5 prozent energie pro 2 grad
logischerweise dann zehn prozent und 10
prozent von denen sehr sehr hohen kosten
das ist ja schon geld also ich finde der
finanzielle anreiz ist genug im system
und ich will auch nicht in einem land
leben wo man nun noch sich bewegt wenn
das geld dafür gibt ich glaube es geht
eher darum will ich das mal in meiner
sprache sagen darf den inneren
schweinehund oder den eigenen blinden
fleck zu überwinden also ich habe auch
eine gasheizung fragen sie mich nicht
weil mein letzter hydraulischer abgleich
war aber das sorgt schon alleine dafür
dass vielleicht 15 prozent energie
gespart werden kann und wenn man das tut
lauter kleine maßnahmen das klingt immer
so banal als der energie- und
klimaminister h weg sagt tausch dem
duschkopf auf sport 30 energie höhere
ein blues kopf von putin retten wenn man
aber die summe sieht dann kommt doch
ganz schön was zusammen und das mal 40
millionen haushalte also sagen wir es
gelingt jedem haushalt oder den
allermeisten zehn prozent energie zu
sparen und das mal 40 millionen dann
macht es ein unterschied und darauf
setze ich es ist ja kein spaß den wir
hier haben sondern das ist eine ernste
politische gesellschaftspolitische
situation wenn wir da uns nicht
gegenseitig helfen kommen wir da nicht
durch werden der jemand sagt ich helfe
nur wenn ich noch mal 50 euro krieg
würde ich sagen die christen nicht alter
sagte wirtschaftsminister
in wien
zu dem thema diskutieren nachher im
anschluss ans journal auch maybrit
illner und ihre gäste unter anderem lars
klingbeil und christian lindner und
natürlich finden sie viele infos zum gas
und öl problem bei uns auch online auf
zdf heute
putin soll nicht gewinnen und er soll
europa nicht spalten die eu
zusammenzuhalten war er aber auch schon
in friedenszeiten schwierig es ist
insofern schon ein
bemerkenswerter schritt und ein kraftakt
tatsächlich gelungen ist was
bundeskanzler scholz gestern im
bundestag praktisch schon angekündigt
hat dass alle 27 mitgliedstaaten dafür
stimmen dass die ukraine und moldau den
kandidatenstatus erhalten
georgien hingegen muss sich noch
gedulden auch dort gibt es eine große
sehnsucht an die eu heranrücken zu
dürfen der ukraine und dem direkt an die
eu angrenzenden moldau und diesen
schritt jetzt zu verwehren ihre
angesichts der russischen bedrohung aber
ein europapolitisches desaster gewesen
unna krüger berichtet
30 meter blau und gelb die entscheidung
über den status der ukraine liegt nicht
bei den europaabgeordneten sie nehmen
sie aber vorweg
entscheiden müssen diese 27 ihr ja
kostet die eu nichts ist der ukraine
aber viel wert und trotzdem ende die
debatte erst vor wenigen minuten mit dem
tweet des ratspräsidenten der gipfel
entscheidet für den status der ukraine
und moldau als beitrittskandidaten ein
historischer moment
juli zeh politik ja das ist nur eine
politische botschaft dass gero schiefe
licht zugute und ich sage offen und wir
sind noch weit entfernt von der
mitgliedschaft ein runder es kann noch
jahre dauern oder
dass die entscheidung auf sich warten
ließ liegt am gipfel vor dem gipfel
dieselben 27 staats und regierungschefs
treffen auf die des westlichen balkans
alle sechs länder wollen in die eu die
verhandlungen mit serbien laufen seit
gut acht jahren die mit montenegro seit
zehn jahren auf den beginn der gespräche
warten albanien und nord mazedonien
beide werden im paket verhandelt hier
kommt bulgarien ins spiel dessen
geschäftsführender premier im kopf wohl
eher die eigene regierungskrise hat sein
land blockiert mit historischen
argumenten fortschritte für die ukraine
nicht aber für den westbalkan
entsprechend war die stimmung
eine gute diskussion sagen wir offen und
frei
offenbar so offen dass drei der anwärter
eine zunächst abgesagte pressekonferenz
ohne eu-spitzen durchzogen
bulgarien ist eine schande aber es ist
nicht einfach nur bulgarien
der grund ist die ganze unaufrichtigkeit
dieser erweiterungen
albaniens ministerpräsident hält europa
damit den spiegel vor und trifft die
stimmung daheim wir wissen dass in der
ukraine ein schrecklicher krieg
stattfindet ich würde mich für sie
freuen aber ich werde trotzdem mitleid
mit albanien haben
sie müssen sich zuerst mit uns und nord
mazedonien auseinander setzen uns dann
mit der ukraine
auf dem westbalkan versuche russland
einfluss zu nehmen doch die antwort der
eu darauf herr bitter die anwärter
dann sagen sie mir putin sei ein kranker
mann vielleicht ist er das vielleicht
geht es ihm gut aber ganz sicher dieser
ort sieht nicht sehr gesund aus
unter druck kommt die eu voran ohne
blockiert sie sich selbst lang sind die
tage in brüssel lang genug dass die eu
nur einem tag gleich beide gesichter
zeigt
anne gellinek in brüssel klar für die
ukraine ist das heute ein erfolg aber es
war jetzt gerade schon eindrücklich zu
sehen wie das doch zugleich andernorts
in europa für böses blut sorgte also der
frust und die enttäuschung der länder
des westbalkans die sich von der ukraine
eingeholt und sogar überholt sehen der
hat sich hier deutlich bei diesem
westbalkan gipfel heute vormittag bann
gebrochen die diskussion über eine eu
erweiterung hat ja in den letzten jahren
vor sich hin gedümpelt und eigentlich
gab es den konsens dass die eu im moment
keine neuen länder mehr aufnehmen wollte
diese debatte ist jetzt mit der ukraine
voll wieder zurück und nach der bitteren
kritik der sechs regierungschefs und
chefin des westbalkans hatten die 27
europäer ganz schlicht ein schlechtes
gewissen und hatten das gefühl sie
müssten jetzt noch mal die probleme des
west bei in aller ausführlichkeit
diskutieren bevor sie dann am ende doch
der ukraine und moldau den status des
beitrittskandidaten anheften konnten so
bleibt natürlich die frage wie ob man
die ukraine am ende genauso lange warten
lässt und dann auch den gleichen frust
wie auf dem westbalkan irgendwann
produziert ja ich glaube diese wahl
hatte die eu nicht es war klar dass das
politisch nicht geht dass man der
ukraine einem land im krieg die typ
diese tür nicht verwehren kann was aber
ja auch klar ist ist dass dies eine
völlig symbolische politische
entscheidung ist die erst mal zu nichts
verpflichtet denn wenn man weiter denkt
dass die ukraine tatsächlich in die eu
aufgenommen würde dann hätte man sofort
eins der größten flächen länder der eu
mit einer agrarwirtschaft die riesige
subventionen bekommen würde eine große
bevölkerung die mit anderen ländern eine
sperrminorität bilden könnte all diese
konsequenzen für die eu und ihre
funktionsfähigkeit die hat man heute
erstmal weit weggeschoben weil alle
beteiligten wissen dass der weg der
ukraine in die europäische union noch
einer von jahren vielleicht sogar
jahrzehnten sein wird dankeschön an alle
für die einschätzung und das weiß
natürlich auch ein kiew das eine
beitritts kandidatur noch lange keine eu
mitgliedschaft ist aber dass sich diese
tür nun in aller form geöffnet hat
darauf hatte das land schon lange
gewartet und jetzt im krieg als
unterstützung auch sehnlichst erwartet
dominik löschmeister berichtet schon
jetzt wie in sie in kiew die europa
fahnen die ernennung zum eu
beitrittskandidaten wird das land
stärken hoffen sich viele in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt
sie erlauben uns in die eu aufgenommen
zu werden für uns ist das sehr gut und
wir werden den krieg gewinnen zwischen
hier muss die gesetze werden uns viel
abverlangen wir werden eine menge
verbessern müssen wirtschaft
korruptionsbekämpfung rechts reformen
militärisch aber erzählt russland im
osten der ukraine weitere geländegewinne
die russischen truppen sollen im donbass
inzwischen vor der stadtgrenze von lissy
charts stehen das ziel der russen laut
ukrainischem generalstab die stadt und
damit die ukrainischen truppen hier
einzukesseln die britische bbc begleitet
helfer die versuchen zivilisten aus
musik tanz herauszubringen einst lebten
hier hunderttausend menschen etwa 8000
sollen sich noch in der stadt aufhalten
hier wird es wochen oder vielleicht
monate lang straßenkämpfer geben und
diese leute sollten nicht zurück bleiben
aber sie werden es und viele von ihnen
werden sterben und unter schrecklichen
umständen leben katja muss ihr zuhause
verlassen in dem sie ihren sohn
großgezogen hat sie packt schnell noch
ein paar dokumente ein
wir wissen dass es hier kein happy end
geben wird nachdem eine granate gestern
vor unserem hof eingeschlagen ist haben
wir alle hoffnung verloren ohne hilfe
unser leben zu retten
mehr als 100 dieser mehrfach
raketenwerfer soll russland don was
konzentriert haben von massiven beschuss
ist die rede moskau veröffentlicht heute
auch diese bilder eines militär zuges
der auf dem weg ins kampfgebiet sein
soll das signal der russische angriff
geht weiter
1 12 macht jetzt mit den nachrichten
weiter und da zunächst mit dem
verheerenden erdbeben in afghanistan die
rettungsarbeiten dort sind schwierig an
den zufahrtsstraßen zu der abgelegenen
unglücksregion drohen erdrutsche auch
fehlt es an ausrüstung mittlerweile sind
erste versorgungsflüge aus dem ausland
eingetroffen mehrere hilfsorganisationen
wie auch die bundesregierung sagte
unterstützung für die betroffenen
menschen zu bei dem beben der stärke 5,9
kamen nach vorläufigen angaben
mindestens 1000 menschen ums leben
wenn sie den menschen in afghanistan
helfen wollen das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe hat ein spendenkonto
eingerichtet mit der bahn de 65 104 106
100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf nothilfe
afghanistan nachzulesen auf spenden
punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 8
in den usa hat das oberste gericht das
recht auf das tragen von waffen in der
öffentlichkeit
ausgeweitet dieses recht werde von der
verfassung geschützt so das gericht und
kippte ein gesetz im bundesstaat new
york wonach für das tragen einer
verdeckten handfeuerwaffe eine
ausnahmegenehmigung nötig war
us-präsident beiden reagierte tief
enttäuscht und sagte die entscheidung
widerspreche sowohl den menschenverstand
als auch der verfassung
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
rechnet für herbst mit einer neuen
schweren corona welle gemeinsam mit
seinen länderkollegen bzl lauterbach
vorbereitungen für eine dann wieder
kritischere coroner lage treffen
entsprechende maßnahmen sollen am ersten
juli präsentiert werden hieß es bei der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz in
magdeburg bei der umstrittenen frage des
weiteren angebots kostenloser bürger
tests gab es keine einigung lauterbach
kündigte ein neues konzept an dass er
noch mit finanzminister lindner
abstimmen will
fünfeinhalb wochen nach der landtagswahl
steht die erste schwarz grüne koalition
in nordrhein westfalen bei der
gemeinsamen vorstellung des
koalitionsvertrags mit grünen-chefin
neubauer sagte cdu-ministerpräsident
wüst es sei gelungen vermeintliche
gegensätze zu versöhnen und etwas gutes
zu schaffen der fokus liegt auf mehr
klimaschutz dem ausbau des öffentlichen
nahverkehrs sowie investitionen in
bildung am wochenende müssen noch die
parteitage von cdu und grünen zu stimmen
was ihrem flughafen angeht sind die
berliner ja kummer gewöhnt aber als am
ber zuletzt die schlange vor der
security so lang war dass die leute bis
auf die strasse standen war das doch mal
wieder eine neue stufe auf der nach oben
offenen frustration skala so geht es
aber derzeit nicht nur am berliner
flughafen zu praktisch überall und nicht
nur in deutschland herrscht post
pandemische chaos im flugverkehr
flugausfälle verspätungen und irrwitzige
wartezeiten da erinnert man sich an
prognosen zu beginn der pandemie dass
die auslastung und flugverkehr nie
wieder die selbe sein werde doch die
menschen wollen wieder fliegen und
vielen airlines
flughafenbetreibern und security firmen
fehlt jetzt das personal das in der
pandemie gehen ließen thomas mann
berichtet gestern abend kurz nach 19 uhr
ein passagier sind diese szenen mit
seinem handy im abflugterminal des
düsseldorfer flughafens kommt es zu
rangeleien unter den fluggästen die
teilweise mehr als drei stunden auf den
sicherheitscheck warten müssen die
bundespolizei muss eingreifen schon am
mittag war es hier übervoll die terminal
anzeigen verstecken die endlosen
schlangen durch die große halle hinter
der harmlosen anzeige wartezeit mehr als
20 minuten die gäste in der schlange
sind größtenteils fassungslos
und noch nie erlebt also noch nie erlebt
im schlimmsten urlaubszeiten doch nicht
nur hätte ich mir nicht vorstellen
können dass noch passieren kann also
überraschend aber wenn wir jetzt noch
eineinhalb stunden warten müssen jetzt
wahrscheinlich knapp mit dem fliegen ja
was soll man sagen scheiße viel zu wenig
kontrollpersonal haben die privaten
sicherheitsfirmen eingestellt etwas mehr
als die hälfte der kontroll strecken ist
aktuell besetzt ab morgen soll eine
zweite firma drei weitere strecken
öffnen ein unhaltbarer zustand findet
die gewerkschaft
wenn wir jetzt schon solche bilder haben
wollen wir uns das nicht ausmalen was
dann heißt wenn familien mit kindern in
die warteschlange kommen weil das klar
genauso weitergehen wird haben wir große
sorge dass sich die situation noch
einmal zuspitzen wird die
kontrollierenden verdienen zwischen 19
und 26 euro pro stunde doch fast alle
haben nur befristete teilzeitverträge
eine kontrolleurin erzählt uns von ihrem
alltag sie möchte unerkannt bleiben
als die neue firma übernommen hat wurden
nochmal 100 leute gekündigt um zu sparen
wir sollen außerdem ständig die
schichten wechseln sodass man auch
keinen zweiten job planen kann und dann
wird man von den passagieren beschimpft
wir können doch nichts dafür
auch in bayern sind private
gesellschaften für die
sicherheitskontrollen verantwortlich
schon seit jahren gehören sie allerdings
zu 100 prozent dem land bayern müssen
keinen gewinn machen und sorgen für
problemlose abfertigung wir zahlen
tarifvertrag öffentlicher dienst und
mitarbeiter sind sehr zufrieden wir
haben eine punktation quote von 35
prozent und wir haben auch in der korona
pandemie keinen entlassen diese aufgabe
ist eine hoheitliche aufgabe des staates
in der polizei sprache heißt es
anti-terror-maßnahmen gefahrenabwehr und
diese aufgabe gehört in die hände des
staates und nicht in die hände von
gewinnorientierten sicherheit zu
unternehmen weil das ist das ergebnis
was wir hinter uns sehen ja und hätten
wir die bundesministerin nancy faeser zu
der problematik befragt aus terminlichen
gründen stand sie für ein interview
nicht zur verfügung trotz eines
pressetermins heute morgen in ihrem haus
allerdings gibt es ja nicht nur am boden
probleme es fehlt auch an flugpersonal
und das zum teil auch wiederum weil es
im moment so viele corona fälle gibt und
personal krankheitsbedingt ausfällt und
mit dem thema angesetzt bei der auch
noch mal weiter ein und zwar mit den
plänen der fluglinien für die nächste
zeit da gab es heute neuigkeiten zur
lufthansa frank bethmann wie sieht es da
aus ja die lufthansa reagiert erneut
muss man sagen unter anderem auch das
was wir da gerade gesehen haben
dramatische engpässe bei der abfertigung
hinzu kommen aber auch hausgemachte
probleme bereits am monatsanfang hatte
die airline 900 flüge für juli gecancelt
jetzt kommen weitere
2200 flugausfälle hinzu an den großen
drehkreuzen frankfurt und münchen
gestrichen im juli und august betroffen
innerdeutsche und innereuropäische
strecken
die lufthansa begründet das heute unter
anderem mit streiks bei der
flugsicherheit mit wetterereignissen
aber auch mit einem eben erhöhten
krankenstand in den vergangenen tagen
sei es zu kurzfristigen krankmeldungen
von cruise gekommen heißt es der
luftverkehr kämpft insgesamt nach zwei
jahren gruner und vielen entlassungen
mit zu wenig personal und zu hohen
arbeitsbelastung enorm belastet geht
auch der dax in den morgigen tag r
rutscht heute um fast 1,8 prozent ab auf
nur noch 12
1913 punkte es sind die sorgen ums gas
aber auch um die schwächelnde konjunktur
insgesamt die dem kursbarometer heute
deutliche verluste bescheren und den
deutschen aktienindex weiter in richtung
jahrestief treiben frank bethmann vielen
dank
der bundestag hat einer bafög erhöhung
zugestimmt demnach soll etwa der voerder
höchstsatz für studierende von monatlich
8 161 auf 934 euro steigen und künftig
sollen auch wieder mehr junge menschen
bafög berechtigt sein das ist unter
anderem ein höherer freibetrag auf das
einkommen der eltern vorgesehen
es gibt aktuell eine amtliche
unwetterwarnung des deutschen
wetterdienstes vor schweren gewittern
mit heftigem starkregen und hagel in
teilen von baden-württemberg und von
bayern wo für einige regionen die
warnung zusätzlich vor orkanböen gilt
die finales 2022 haben begonnen die
deutschen meisterschaften in 14
sportarten heute war der erste von vier
wettkampftagen in berlin katrin beyer
beginnt ihren bericht mit dem ersten
titel in einer neuen sportart speed
kanupolo
vier gegen vier mitten auf der spree an
der east side gallery der berliner
verein ksv havel brüder gewinnt das
finale im neuen speed format gegen
rothemühle essen mit 7 zu 3 der schnelle
und spannende sport hat einen ersten
deutschen meister einmal durch die mitte
in den prenzlauer berg 7 km weiter
nördlich in der max schmeling halle
hatte auch leonie adam einen höhenflug
die neue deutsche meisterin im trampolin
zeigte bei schrauben und salti die beste
ausführung die 29 jährige gewinnt ihren
fünften titel
schlussläuferin lena meißner sichert der
triathlon mix raleigh staffel aus
buschhütten den deutschen meistertitel
im olympiastadion und verteidigt das
team seinen erfolg über die
sprintdistanz vor potsdam und berlin
und morgen sind die finales live bei uns
im zdf zu sehen ab 13 uhr und hier geht
es jetzt zwischen angekündigt bei
maybrit illner weiter gleich nach dem
wetter und um 0.30 meldet sich dann
christopher wehrmann mit unserem
heutigen update bis morgen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend schon heute vormittag
entwickelte sich ein gewittertief hier
über frankreich und inzwischen haben die
gewitter ja auch uns hier in deutschland
erreicht zum einen hier im westlichen
nordrhein westfalen vor allen dingen
aber auch in bayern und in baden
württemberg sie sehen wie hier diese
zirn schirm aus frankreich heran kommt
er wird noch das saarland und
rheinland-pfalz überdecken und da gibt
es da auch kräftige gewitter die
gewitterzelle aus dem allgäu die hat
inzwischen das allgäu verlassen und
peilt das fünfseenland an wo im
nordosten werden sie in dieser nacht
davon gar nichts mitbekommen und auch
morgen bleibt es zwischen dem erzgebirge
und der ostseeküste sehr sonnig sonst
aber ist es darf ich und schwül und es
gibt immer noch kräftiger unwetter das
sind gewitter die mit starkregen hagel
und sturmböen verbunden sind
extrem heftiger starkregen bedeutet laut
deutschem wetterdienst mindestens vier
zentimeter regen in einer stunde klingt
überschaubar diese vier zentimeter pro
stunde
entsprechend 50 liter pro quadratmeter
das sind 4 putzeimer stellen wir uns vor
dass diese menge regen auf einen hektar
feld das sind 10.000 solcher
quadratmeter ein großes fußballfeld dann
sind das 40 tausend solcher heime pro
stunde zu viel um direkt im boden zu
versickern ist diese fläche abschüssig
fließen die wassermassen gebündelt ins
tal und können dort kleine bäche in
reißende flüsse verwandeln sturzfluten
auslösen wenigstens das wochenende wird
stand heute ruhiger auf wiedersehen